it is not me
um there's some there's some elements
that that are truthful first
act really terrified me but by the times
we got to act two and three I was like
well he's really taking us on an
adventure that is quite exciting you
know uh culmining from whatever the
perception has been in the media the
internet
um you know whatever blips in my life
that have occurred that have gone public
as as a result of being in the public
eye some sense of knowledge of my
interviews and the things that
interested me in this path that spoke to
me and it was like a fantasy
found a way into that room Mick
see myself doing more of this stuff I
think I might have a real gift for it